I think in the same way that her father
was absolutely determined that his
daughter should learn the ropes in the
shadow of his kingship so too was
Elizabeth Keane that Charles learned and
that she mentored him so that he was
prepared no one could have known that he
was going to spend more than a half a
Century Learning the ropes of being King
but certainly in the later years of
horrend the queen would share important
government documents of course with the
blessing of the government so that
Charles could understand the legislation
of the days that he could get involved
as we know he did because he lobbied
ministers over certain things but it was
very important to the queen that if he
was going to have all these years in
Waiting then he really needed a good
grasp of how things worked and she was
very generous in that respect and more
recently in her reign of course you know
the queen put down the foundations for
Charles's future the Commonwealth for
example the head of the Commonwealth is
a title that the queen passed on to
Charles before she died it was it was a
guaranteed to go to him and this wasn't
a hereditary title so in all of those
things she was Paving the way for the
Future King Charles III her Legacy
it has to be one of Duty before self you
know I think she will long be remembered
as Elizabeth the Great
Elizabeth the steadfast she was quite
simply always there
[Music]